it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Oh what in the world what's going
on everybody
movie fights it's happening hashtag
movie fights live God give a shout-out
to my little friend Percival and Alla
nation who dude so we are in JD was like
throwing a weird like sound effects for
joining us everybody we're in the second
phase of the oh I almost got Dan Marilla
thon and Dan is fighting oh this is one
of my favorite fights when these guys
normally they collaborate today they are
at odds sometimes when you're
collaborating you might be at odds over
a joke or whatever but today only one
will leave here the victor it's the
honest trailer fights and first off we
have the head writer for Phantom
entertainment he's a former movie fights
champion of really was my reign but yes
hate to wear the strap means to wear the
strap okay Spencer go thank you thank
you it's not her privilege oh heck yeah
good to have you sitting right here next
to me oh the man in the middle player
number two he's not a strong writer
winner of the first honest trailer
fights and at the that was at the 2018
women in film event and all-around swell
guy nicely manicured beard Joestar thank
you they're happy happy to be here with
the full team of honest trailers writers
heck yeah
the man on you know from all over screen
junkies he is the reigning movie fights
champion you know it does damage the
Schmo down all over the place Dan Morell
what's going on buddy how are you how
I'm fighting fatigue today how what what
do you what do you feel were you up all
night
door neighbor's had a night they were
home oh yeah music they were yelling it
was crazy
so I'm not gonna pull like that newborn
baby card already sleeps only a memory
exactly Dan thank you Oh Dan thank you
for going through everything that
journey to make it here today and
deciding these fights today will be
myself and Lomb Dan calling lawn Harris
and Danielle Radford one holding it down
the fact zone the whole show so don't
think you can get away with anything
anybody all right
don't even try to get a fast pass there
professor and Danielle Radford our
social media ambassador please tell the
folks how that works
hi guys so the way that this will work
is that there are lots of really fun
polls on Twitter I encourage you to join
those get into the discussion on movie
fights live because I will be picking
out comments throughout the show but we
do have a poll and that poll works as a
tiebreaker and the only one that works
for that is the poll on youtube if you
have any questions about how that works
it's gonna be down in the description
below you can bug someone in the chat
and the poll does not go up until
everyone's giving their first answer
because it's supposed to be about the
answers not necessarily you know it's
about the debate it's not necessarily
about which answer you like the most and
I don't know man you can probably get
some past me yeah I mean you never know
I mean you gotta wake up early to get
something passed Danielle but every
all right you know what
without further ado jte drop that Sega's
package
[Music]
yeah thanks door and again the first
person of four points wins three regular
questions top two players after those
three questions move on to the speed
around then it's anybody's ballgame here
we go with question number one so a lot
of folks still can't get over I mean
come on get over it already though for
real
but they can't get over that Robert
Pattinson is our new Batman so we ask
these three who is the worst possible
choice to play Batman possible whoa done
and for some reason man covering this
back I mean that also had some dramatic
so I think it's the current affair yes
nineties TV some things is a new slice
of the wheel so I'm gonna give an easy
one Denton tan and minor key for SVU
Motown patrons a good investment if you
can get that on the wheel man
yeah man listen $5,000 is all it took to
you've each made excellent points
the judging starts now Spencer your
choice for the worst to play back I do
like Pattinson I'm on board with the Pat
man yeah get up and evidene up a button
but the way I arrived at this was I was
thinking about what you need for a great
Batman and then thinking of who inhabits
like the opposite of all those
characteristics so you need to be
convincingly portray someone with like a
maniacal Drive and focus to play Batman
this mint does not have that someone who
can convincingly portray like peak human
physical ability someone who can pull
off the charm of a Bruce Wayne like the
suaveness the debonair heir of a Bruce
Wayne and someone who can play
themselves off as a brilliant detective
and who I think could never do any of
those things is America's current and
always sad sack William H Macy I guess
I'll elaborate in future arguments but
for now enough said alright whm William
H Macy
oh man she's that picture of him with
the balloons okay Joe well help for one
thing congratulations on the rock on
your finger
ah thanks yeah this will not be taken to
account and it was good don't want to be
I just you know I'm here to be with my
family and to win a lot of issues going
to this man trying to play the bat some
are on the business end some are on the
actual he would just onset produce a
terrible Batman in a final product his
name Steven Seagal present-day Steven
Seagal specifically there's a lot of
problems that go into Steven Seagal a
lot of problems in that picture picture
as you stretch that picture
yeah what's the aspect ratio sweet sweet
that is Steven Seagal well I won't sighs
shame Steven Seagal I will everything
else shame Steven Seagal first issue is
you know there's no way he goes without
you know some kind of weird ponytail or
something so immediately you're you're
killing the iconic character by adding a
ponytail opening in the back of it he's
he's actually a cop which means he might
be at odds with the vigilante nature of
the character and thus maybe argue with
the writers to choose to change the core
concept of Batman yeah yeah I think it's
also just gonna be a troublesome shoot
he has it worked with Warner Brothers
since 97 his contract ended and they
never renewed it and so there might be a
lot of studio issues there this might
become a very troubled shoot that
produces a very very subpar terrible the
worst Batman Steven Seagal Seagal subpar
terrible Batman Dan we're at a new age
for Batman it's a new it's the dawning
of a new era so what what what is what
does not work for Batman right now what
do we need right now we need Batman to
be energetic I think we need youth or at
least energy we need a zest for life we
just need some indication that whoever's
playing Batman has any interest
whatsoever in doing the part someone who
does not have any of those things is
Bruce Willis Bruce was exists that's all
I can really say think in your mind when
was the last time you saw Bruce Willis
bring some life into a role what does
the last time you watched a Bruce Willis
role and you thought well he really put
a lot into that we gave Bruce Willis
credit for for doing well in glass
literally because he did not fall asleep
on screen that is the bar that Bruce
Willis has to clear at this point
everything that Batman needs right now a
Bruce Willis will not provide and to add
on to that
only will the performance itself be a
trainwreck the promotional tour will be
an absolute disaster because if there's
anything Bruce Willis hates more than
acting at this point in this life it's
doing interviews and the promotional
tour that this Batman movie would
require Bruce Willis would not kill him
it would kill the industry of journalism
entertainment in otherwise physically
because he would murder everyone all of
them
so Bruce Willis worst possible choice in
every aspect for Batman alright Dan
claiming Bruce Willis will murdered
journalists fighting out everybody thank
you so much for bringing that up Dan you
asked when the last time Bruce Willis
has displayed
you know zest for life well zest for
life put putting that aside but like
presenting himself as like a credible
threat it is in his promotional tours
and that's why I think he still has it
in him to play the back never you say
yourself murdering a journalist he's
never seemed more intense and more
intimidating than the junket for read to
when he's with them Mary what's-her-name
from weeds and he looks like he is about
to kill the person sitting across from
there's a genuine Menace that he's
capable of channeling and I think the
right director could bring that out of
him he's menacing what he doesn't need
to be but did you see death wish she
literally plays a vigilante who murders
people and he walks to the home I think
what he's doing there Dan is he's really
channeling the the Bruce Wayne that
we're gonna get in a Dark Knight Returns
to us style story an old broken bat
years in the future he's tired he's over
he's got to go out for one last poor
person punch before he finally hangs up
the cape one last PPP I disagree on all
counts about sweet sweet William H Macy
for one thing I think is sweet sweet
well if he grew out the the standard
Macy stash I think there's a Batman with
that blond mustache it's so scary like
before before he even says I'm Batman
I'm like whoa what's up with this guy I
better not punch that that lady in
Steeler purse in what universe does
William H Macy have the spine to say no
I'm not shaving the mustache denote mage
Macy says to anyone before they even
finish their request okay
see I think Batman is all about sort of
the the the inner torment turmoil that's
like burning up inside you and William H
Macy is shown he's got that there's
Boogie Nights many faces yeah bogey
night and also just the unstoppable
resolve they showed us the Shoveler and
Mystery Men but that is that's my
unstoppable Batman with that little bit
of darkness like that's a that's a great
Batman he was a leader he had energy he
was rules and just you're just pulling
for Mystery Men well that's one because
that wasn't playing off his few combines
reputation against a loser in every
medal Fargo he's a loser wild hogs he's
a loser the cooler loser
Jurassic every loser this man is a
cinematic loser and you want to turn
into an Antonio what's up man so was
Chris Pratt in Parks and Rec and that
Sutton Sun he glowed up and will he
makes Mayci Breaux and he was a bro in
Parks and Rec he's a brother he was a
schlubby loser and the Hitman he became
a buff hero William H Macy could become
a buff and so he makes Maisie five foot
nine 160 pounds you know who else is
that me I am NOT Batman I am not I do
not have the physical presence to play
that's what people said about Michael
Keaton yeah that's executives - he's too
slight he can't do it and you know one
of the people that said that about
Michael Keaton this is why I want to
talk about Steven Seagal this is a true
story that I read on the internet which
means it's definitely true in 1989
Steven Seagal made a bet with a guy
named Matt Ella Allen there's a
screenwriter now he went under item Ungh
other things the talking cat movie nine
lives but in 1999 he worked for Steven
Seagal and Steven Seagal bet him $100
that Batman was going to be a flop
because Michael Keaton was a wimp lost
that bet and had to pay Matt Allen $100
exam if you don't think that $100 Batman
Vendetta has not been eating at Steven
Seagal soul for the last thirty years
exactly and then nobody will be more
motivated to come back and prove what a
real tough guy Batman is that he's been
in itself proves that Steven Seagal
doesn't understand what goes into Batman
you know it's so important in big move
these days global distribution you know
who's Batman movie wouldn't be
distributed in Estonia or either Ukraine
because he's not welcome to those
countries cuz he's friends with Putin
Stephen sickles powerhouses and Bruce
Willis for that matter having their
movies are only released at the
Philippines they're entirely financed by
like Malaysian government embezzlement
running outside man let me bring up that
point if you're gonna if you're gonna
kick off a Batman you're gonna kick off
another shared universe or something so
Ghul puts out a movie maybe every other
week he's so busy already like what is
he gonna make room to do a Batman movie
when he's doing like viewer to kill and
thrill knife you guys very rightly
pointed out that there is a certain
darkness to William H Macy but it's not
a heroic darkness like Batman it's not a
focused rage darkness whereas Steven
Seagal there's a psycho darkness to him
that actually does really well with
Batman he seems like somebody who would
kill or or at least fight crime whether
anyone asked him to or not like he does
in Steven Seagal la man could but could
he because you know we saw what Sam
Jackson tried to do in Captain Marvel
were like he can barely move like Steven
Seagal is even worse off like Henning
Keaton also famously could barely move
and he did a great you put if you put
Segal who can already just barely do
this like if you put him in an even more
constrictive Batsuit like what does he
do just get wheeled around like Hannibal
Lecter that's the brilliance of Aikido
like like Yuri Rock Michael Keaton
scenes like he's throwing he's only
moving from the waist up like there's
one stiff kick here and there but he's
really just doing judo but that's what
I'm saying Segal doesn't even have that
mobility at this point so that is right
out like he might actually die in the
suit and I would say that the point that
you just made about Steven Seagal is the
same for what do you made to Macy first
of all I think you can put on the bulk
and secondly as you mentioned the
physical parts as far as being in top
peak physical shape it could easily be
cheated with hammer tricks himself could
also be cheated to put on the weight if
he can't put on them any Dan correct me
if I'm wrong here but Aronofsky wanted
to do the crazy homeless Batman right
where's just like a weird dude on the
street was an Aronofsky that wanted to
do that then if you want to take that
Batman that's why you made to Macy's
Batman man just like crazy mustache
Macy's bed
yeah the other thing you guys are no no
you you're neglecting to mention the
present your final thoughts Spencer
let's go to final five I've talked about
how sad and unintimidating and just a
sad sack pushover William H Macy is
real-life aside in in these roles but
also I think what's missing is the Bruce
Wayne argument of all these whereas I
can totally see Steven Seagal and Bruce
Willis pulling off egotistical playboy
billionaire philanthropist whereas blim
H Macy could not charm his way out of a
Fargo auto parts dealership there he can
he cannot pull off either side of the
role at least Cloney played a good Bruce
Wayne and I really think that Willis and
what's-his-name since the ball could do
the same William H Macy is failing at
every conceivable part of a Batman Thank
You Spencer you know I disagree I can
see William H may see in the boardroom
of a Wayne Enterprises Prizes meeting
charming those people with a wink and a
smile there is there is a charm
- William AIT's may see it might not be
a leading man charm but there is a charm
there that that can that can channel a
great Bruce Wayne and a guy you know
I've covered how scary of a Batman he
would be he is actually terrifying in
Boogie Nights when he's finally had
enough and he's broken and that horrible
New Year scene happens like that's
that's a Batman thing Steven Seagal his
hair is just strips of velcro that is
not that's not Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne
requires like there's a bit of a range
and Steven Seagal just doesn't have that
he can't be charming he can't wink he he
he doesn't have one speed as an actor he
has no speeds and I think that that's
challenge challenge for someone who has
to play basically two characters in one
you know and you sort of argued maybe he
could be the the alley guy Steven Seagal
is not a weird homeless Batman he is an
entrepreneur entrepreneur sir
he's had an energy drink alone
he licensed out his name to a to a line
of swords and knives he's a businessman
which also I think sort of interrupts
you know that the scheduling issues with
with filming a movie he has he's got his
his broken hands and so many dumb jars
but here's the biggest issue with Steven
Seagal that I want to talk about JT can
you throw the picture of him back up
thank you you look at the size of that
goatee that big giant black square now
picture the Batman mask around it it
will blend directly into the mask and
make his mouth whole look unnaturally
small and no one will be able to look
away from that I think that don't that
that in itself is a terrible choice for
Batman because if you just picture that
tiny little square where is lip is as
the only hole in the Batman mask like
that looks ridiculous
that no sir a solid chin all right Joe
playing the goatee card dan as you just
mentioned Steven Seagal is of the
businessman which means he will bring a
lot of personal experience to the role
of Bruce Wayne and like I said secondly
I can't think of anybody who would be
more energized for a chance to be back
on top than Steven Seagal
we made to Macy I think of the three of
our choices is easily the best actor he
can he can adjust he's done a lot of
different kinda roles he's not always
the sad sack he's done comedy he's done
drama he does a lot of different kinds
of roles and I think he's the most
adaptable which I don't think makes him
the worst choice he can't play a Bruce
Wayne he's not a Bruce Bruce George
Cloney Bruce Wayne but there are lots of
different kinds of Bruce Wayne's Michael
Keaton was a little more of an
introspective one so I think the way mhm
AC is a great actor and if he was tapped
to be the bat I think he'll become what
the role needs him to be Bruce Willis it
feels like he sleeps on the set and they
just shake him awake every minute before
the camera rolls in just says his vines
and goes back to sleep
the energy he has when he doesn't like
doing interviews is the most energy I
see not of Bruce Willis
and well over a deck
Julia mentioned the whole Dark Knight
Returns things like oh we could do a
Dark Knight Returns beat again we just
did that we just did the Dark Knight
Returns if that's the only speed that
Bruce Willis can do it's a complete
retread of what we just did with Ben
Affleck and it's not this though it's
not the way that this franchise is going
it's not going that way because we just
did it people don't want to see that
take again because they want something
new and they want something different
Bruce Willis just doesn't really care
for anything anymore and if I'm looking
at the worst possible choice for Batman
it's a Batman that's boring it's a
Batman that's uninspired I think way it
mates Maci will do his best as an actor
and really transform himself for the
role I think Steven Seagal if you told
me that Steven Seagal is gonna be the
next Batman I would ask you when do
tickets go on sale because I have to go
see this it may not be great but people
are gonna go see it if you said Bruce
Willis is Batman people kind of go oh
and that's the worst possible thing I
can imagine for Batman right now and
that's why I go with Bruce Willis all
right tick tock time good stuff three
weird Batman what's going on the facts
oh it is true what Joe said Darren
Aronofsky had pitched a take on Batman
year one the Frank Miller comic which
would have involved Bruce Willis losing
the family fortune after his parents are
killed
making him homeless that is true Steven
Seagal just a little back Dargis he's a
seventh level black belt in Aikido and
was one of the very first martyrs to
operate an Aikido dojo in Japan one more
thing I have to say Spencer being a
loser in all right one taking us to the
facts own sponsor by Circuit City okay I
really enjoyed these arguments this is
there was a lot of great stuff and you
guys presented three potentially bad
Batman but two of the three I came out
intrigued about at the end of this and
that left only one potentially bad
Batman
that did not get dinged is hard but
Spencer I mean they brought up the
Keaton point I think there could be a
little bit of that flavor and William H
Macy and you know the played us I mean
the similar in the superhero vein with
the Shoveler from Mystery Men a fun
underrated movie there and they could be
kind of turned that scary level as well
so yeah just got me asking too many
questions about it and then man Steven
Seagal is a psycho weird edgy Batman
you know his ill-fitting suit aside and
and the goatee and everything yeah
worried about that methyl if you haven't
seen the video of him doing slow-motion
Aikido
like against guys who are like obviously
paid by about Vladimir Putin just walk
gently approach him yeah that kind of
Batman but Dan again I think you just
like the epitome of your argument was
like you nailed it at the end there it's
just like oh really
whereas these two I'm Carly ah so I
gotta go Dan I gotta go Dan lon
yeah when you hear the responses Dan
seem to have picked the most
conventionally appropriate actor to play
Bevan but after all of a sudden I
thought he had a really great closing
argument and yeah I'm a little intrigued
to see the blond mustache and see if
it's a callback dan you're getting that
point Bruce Willis Danielle what did the
poll have to say alright with 59% of the
vote it was present-day Steven Seagal
that's a 24% William each may see a 16%
some of the other things that we got we
got quite a few DJ Qualls we had a few
Gilbert Gottfried's we submit pops and
then someone say Joey Lawrence would
make the best one and of course busy
builder man coming through with a great
Photoshop present a Steven Seagal in a
Batman costume yeah oh man yeah that's
cuz that guy's powered by a Tibetan goji
juice powered Steven Seagal energy drink
yeah Bruce Willis I could just picture
him coming out at comic-con a lot of
fanfare Dan taking that first point Joe
Spencer looking to get on the ball
always let's go to question number two
so Father's Day this Sunday hmm text
your dad so you know send your dad an
email this Sunday
what is we asked who this fun what is
the best father child character duo from
any movie okay best father child pair up
in any movie and we're gonna start with
player number two so far Joe star you
know how dads can be great they can they
can really help develop your character
they can teach of morals they can teach
you wrong from right but just as often
as enough as not uh they're awful
definite there's a reason there's a term
called daddy issues you did and so I'm
gonna go with the
and who just sort of sidesteps all the
really bad stuff and just goes for the
good stuff like keeping you safe and
stuff like that and I'm gonna go with
the t800 and his son John Connor as Sara
says herself who better to be a dad to
John the guy that can't feel only ships
up to do his job does it well and then
when it's time to go away falls in some
lava with a very encouraging thumbs up I
can't have a better father figure to a
boy that's supposed to lead the the
forces of humanity against evil robots
in the future than that alright going
with the father figure in child
relationship t800 Schwarzenegger and
John Connor thank you Joe dan I will
going with the biological father son
relationship oh I can head I'm going
with one that is not what you would call
the ideal is an imperfect relationship
but it's one that I think gets at the
core of what a lot of fathers and sons
go through and that is a Henry Jones
senior and Henry Jones jr. aka Indiana
Jones from Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade what I like about this duo is
like I said they are not the perfect
father-son team as a matter of fact they
start the movie off somewhat estranged
from each other there's been a wedge
between them a wall between them a lot
of grief over the death of Indiana and
Jones's mother some some some
imperfections some bad blood from the
past and what makes that movie so great
or one of the reasons that movie so
great is that you see these two learn
basically reintroduce themselves to each
other and learn how to communicate as
adults not as two people that are kind
of caught in the shadows of a childhood
or in the shadows of being a father
raising a child alone but it's two
adults who meet later in life and are
able to understand the truth of being a
parent and the truth of being a child
and I think that that speaks a lot more
than than the storybook relationship
that you've seen a lot of movies and
that's what I like so much
about it it's the fact that they're not
perfect and that they do learn from each
other because that's how life works so
much so that that I went with those two
that's how life works thank you Dan
around the horn dispenser I went with
something even more conventional getting
progressively more conventional Steve
Martin and his daughter in father of the
bride it's so sweet I see Danny I got a
matter of Danielle's envisioning it
who doesn't want Steve Martin as their
dad he's so sweet there's such a sense
of humor and a wisdom with him and she
Annie is like a very well-adjusted 22
year old architect who made a who met a
great guy and this is a relationship
that's that's pushed to the limits by
something that's very relatable which is
a wedding but really a daughter growing
up and moving out and becoming her own
person and a father's sometimes strange
but ultimately healthy and relatable way
of dealing with that so it's just a
perfect portrayal of of the love between
between a father and and their child and
it doesn't take superheroes or crazy
robots or massive adventure to bring
that out and yet it's still not boring
and incredibly touching all right
Spencer hates superheroes and robots
find out you guys I hate superheroes and
robots I just I don't know I don't know
examples you guys listed or even like
examples of that of a father child
dynamic like yours is John Connor does
more teaching of the Terminator than the
other way around it's like this muddled
thing we're like Kyle Reese this is dad
I think you'll find in a few years that
your daughter teaches you a lot at the
same time like you really erased you're
erasing Sarah Connors a nuclear families
put it to them other members of the
immediate family and father of the bride
I can't remember their names Steve
Martin's wife I think there's enough
our sons as a Vulcan it's just a weird
dynamic that's not really like father
anything it's like boy and robot friend
who he then has to euthanize no I
disagree actually I think the
interesting thing about the the t800 arc
is that he learns about humanity via
fatherhood and via taking care of this
child and I think that's really
interesting - all the weird human things
that crappy dads do that'll screw up
their kids the the Joneses man that's
that's a screwed-up relationship right
there he left him alone all the time
reading his books he didn't teach him
any useful skills like the kid almost
became skillful like just in spite of
his dad they they bang the same lady in
Germany or in Austria that's probably
gonna be some therapy you know the
relationship just seems to be in high
stakes were tied to a chair and the
Nazis are trying to set us on fire
situations versus like actual simple
father-son stuff whereas the t800 and
John fix a car together learn how to
shoot a minigun together well he sits
around and watches just like I did and I
turned out great the Terminator 1800
doesn't have to do any of the hard stuff
he gets the clean air mr. senior know
mr. Shue is very much to see you're
talking about the relationship like it
stopped it look like it ended where it
starts the movie ends with Henry Jones
senior looking at his child about to be
consumed by the very quest that consumes
him his entire life which is this this
this
thus obsession with the Holy Grail that
moment where he's holding his son over
this chasm this bottomless chasm in
Indiana Jones is saying dad I can get it
I can get it and he says Indiana let it
go that that is the completions are
learning from each
that guy when Indiana Jones was
hypnotized by a weird Indian dart God
about to kill him that's the first
moment where he becomes a father up
until that point they're really like
KOAT Lee's an older coworker they're
kind of buddies and that's not like a
father-son relationship until the very
end when you know oh maybe I should have
been a dad that's the other thing is
everyone looks at it as this is what a
conventional and that's it your
relationship is a very conventional
father-daughter relationship an egg
ative way of you your mind person all of
that that's true that is part of his
character but he is never putting that
on her he's not he's oh he goes out to
the supermarket to freak out about hot
dog buns he's not screaming in her face
like I can't let you go he's around like
he loves family who he's never met
before and then he lies about it well he
falls off the balcony and comes trying
to sabotage the wedding he doesn't know
he's not set up he was an awkward
perfect opportunity to sabotage the
entire wedding when the fiance blows it
up and he convinces him to get back with
his daughter at great personal expense
to himself that is a self-sacrificing
dad and that's the guy he's always been
he didn't just turn into that because of
a Jesus cup or I just want to clarify
one thing the the question it's not
who's the best dad what's the best
relationship the wording of the question
is what is the best father child
character duo from an angry so you could
have a totally dysfunctional duo then
you could have a crappy one but mine is
an actual except my father and devorah
find out we're going to device for Steve
Martin's dad high jinks whereas I think
the t800 and John are actually a duo
they learn from each other they grow
from each other they're sort of like a
union koifish thing you know circling
one can't the one can't really exist
without the other whereas again she's
more of a platform for like Steve
Martin's hijinks to do horrible toxic
dad things and the the Joneses are just
sort of at odds in
until that end where yes he does have
his come to Jesus and God your
sean.conner he's so good and I just
always want to give you props for it but
I think as a duo like they're always
just sort of at odds in terms of like a
father child dynamic I it's it's sort of
toxic and it doesn't work whereas these
two are the characters actually feed off
of each other they're arcs are directly
connected to each other that's why I
like them as a father child duo well
I'll argue that Annie banks is not like
a cutout nothing character she has a
personality she's driven she's smart she
does she's fallible she interprets the
blender the wrong way and freaks out and
just because her problems are relatable
doesn't mean that she's not a character
like because the problems aren't
Universal and the things that we all go
through the fact that they pulled that
off means that it's a it's a great
achievement where is the John coming
like John Connor programs the t800 like
30 years down the line or something to
save himself it's just so muddled I
don't get what the relationship is with
them its protector but it's also teacher
but it's also brother yeah dad and when
John has to say who who the t800 is to
him he doesn't say this is my dad he
says this is Uncle Bob uncle that comes
into town for a week and then lowers
himself into lava you know like Oh makes
them lower him into lava which is how he
looks at Hemi that's him being clever
cuz the t800 has been teaching him tons
of survival skills and so yes your final
thoughts please Joe dad would just lead
to a whole lot of questions uncle bob is
hem smartly saying don't ask me any more
questions and the response to that is
okay Uncle Bob clearly they have
succeeded again like I think these two
come as a pair whether it's learning why
you can't just kill people all the time
or keeping this kid safe no matter what
and sort of like a lot but also like
allowing him room to stand up on his own
and do his own things and help save the
day
by the end of the movie he's taught John
like a sense of responsibility almost at
the beginning he's just riding around
with Budnick from salute your sorts too
you could be mine a great
dropping at the end he's because of the
t800 sort of guiding and helping long
yeah Sarah Connor taught him some stuff
but the t800 is really the one that
helped his character get into focus not
like character on the page really moral
character and III think that that's
really really cool and they do it
without it it's the most pure version of
a father child do it without all any of
the extra like I'm too controlling of my
daughter or I was a crap dad to my son
and but I had a moment of validation and
that means I'm a great dad I think it's
it's all there on the page right there
with the t800 in John Connor
thank you Joe also to be noted but Nick
popped up in the last season of
Diff'rent Strokes yeah I again I feel
like we're cutting Sarah Connor out of
the picture a lot in this Terminator
John Connor thing I mean the Terminator
learns a lot of stuff from John but I
don't think just learning something and
becoming someone's friend makes you a
great father figure with Georgian and
Annie banks again I feel like it it's
it's a typical dynamic but it's not
something that you haven't seen in a lot
of other rom-coms and a lot of other
movies I think what makes for me the
Henry Jones and Indiana Jones dynamic
more believable is that it gets to I
think the truth of not just the men that
these people are separately or or the
authority of a father figure but the
idea that together they are better and
they don't know that until the end of
the movie which is that by the end of
the movie they both have understand they
understand the importance of family I
have a very imperfect relationship with
my dad I really relate to that movie
because it's this idea that you know not
every relationship is the storybook and
you grow up together in the same house
and you know you go home on the weekends
and you play catch and all that stuff so
I think that there's a truth there
that's not necessarily reflected in the
idyllic picture of a father child
relationship and that truth is that
sometimes you have to revisit things
later in life and the reason they're a
great duo is that by the end of it
they're they realize that they're not
neither one of them are fully whole
until they're with each other and it
fills that void it's the void that
Indiana Jones has been trying
Phil's entire life by globe-trotting
around and doing all this stuff it's the
boy that Henry Jones has been trying to
tell his entire life by looking for the
Grail that's why at the end of the movie
he's okay with telling Indiana Jones to
let it go it's because they have
actually progressed in their
relationship they've rediscovered each
other and I think that's so much more
true in a lot of ways to how parents and
kids a lot of times interact with each
other and what that relationship can
mean then just like the Hollywood
version of what a parent in the kid are
which is like oh you taught me something
or you're really protective it's this
idea of like these are complicated
relationships that evolve over our
lifetimes and that's what I love about
that movie and those two characters
thanks Dan Spencer you are a gifted
rhetorical genius stand because you had
me almost believing that the
relationship between Indiana Jones and
his bed is not the Hollywood version of
a father-son relationship when they're
hunting Nazis on SEPA lands together and
chasing after the Holy Grail after being
like stranded on an epic quest like what
are you talking about this movie is
slapstick this movie you're in viewing
this with the depth that I'm glad you
found there but it's just not on the
screen he's a he's like just the Indies
opposite and like played four jokes for
90% of the movie until again too little
too late he realizes he should have been
there at the end and has a brilliant
moment and that his whole character is
is amazing because of Sean Connery's
performance there's nothing inherent in
that character that that's especially
moving or especially father-like except
for Sean Connery isms like you love him
and that's why you love that character I
think I've already said enough about
about the t800 and John Connor who I
don't really get there buddy that's his
robot friend it's like the et Elliott
relationship like what are they to each
other are they dating
then again like it's complicated like so
many father-son relationships it's
complicated and father the bride shows
you that like even the normal the
nuclear family father-daughter
relationship is not without its trials
it's not without its challenges it's not
without its extreme love and its bonds
and and what a father is willing to do
is more than just protecting his
daughter it's about and the daughter on
her and it is able to express so much
gratitude and love toward dad back that
yeah it is a healthy relationship
on-screen and I think that's beautiful
and doesn't happen very often time
alright happy Father's Day don't get DM
your dad first in fact we gotta talk
about guys that is not lava that's
molten steel factory alright
at the volcano hey Josie you didn't
teach his son anything we know we taught
him at least one thing and that is how
to count to 20 in Greek I have to bring
it up it's there in the movie hmm and
then finally Steve Martin does have a
leg Nina banks play by day and Keaton
Colton plays Maddy bags come on get your
Banks is right I think your banks
straight everybody I mix please go ahead
and tell us what who you thought took
this I mean three really strong
arguments I was actually going with Joe
for a long time I felt like you know
like there were a lot of good counter
arguments against it I did really like
you speaks about like the Terminator
taught John Connor to do stuff so he's
like dad like but I felt like he got
kind of eliminated by a lot of the
counter-argument so it really came down
to Spencer versus Dan you know I got a
lot of great responses from both of them
I thought you know like I really liked
what they was saying about their adults
that Kirk came together later in life
that sort of started the relationship
but ultimately I thought Spencer focus
the most of the relationship the the
father/daughter relationship that George
and Annie banks had and father of the
bride I'm going with Spencer all right
that's one for Spencer so yeah I went a
little bit differently here I thought
Spencer like what it was kind of put
upon by everybody to bring up Annie as
being more than an afterthought like he
literally said she has a personality and
it's like he seemed like just like such
an afterthought after like the headline
of Steve Martin and I you know truth be
told I can't name that actresses name it
didn't come up I wouldn't have known the
character's name and I feel like we
didn't do justice to that part of this
duo question so for me it came down to
Joe and Dan I thought Dan had a lot of
great points but Spencer then I thought
helped Joe's argument with a potential
takedown that he attempted when he said
what is the t800 of John is he a
protector or is he student is he friend
that's how oftentimes real-life
relationships work and I you know I was
a little iffy about Joe's choice but at
the end of the day by a little bit I
gotta go Joe Danielle
Wow so we're locked it 1-1 here Joe and
Spencer where we at with the poles well
this won't happen with 28% of the vote
it is George and Annie banks and with
21% of the vote it is t800 and John
Connor so taking my personal affinity
4,800 and John Connor out of it you all
know all I've ever wanted in my life was
a robot to give me a thumbs up on
looking over the arguments these were
all all of these were fantastic one
thing I've gotta agree with Spencer wait
does that Dan is rhetorically very good
at all of this I feel like there was a
lot of really good hitting back I wish I
would have heard more Pro reasons from
Joe about the t800 felt like it was a
little bit more defensive so ultimately
I'm gonna have to agree with the
internet and go with Henry Jones senior
Henry Jones jr. all right Dan takes the
point vaults out to a 200 lead nicely
done there what were there any other
choices I mean I was thinking like you
know a Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker
horse that was in there there was Ida
kiss pinch and scout which every on
doing quite a Logan Logan and Maura
Mufasa just overwhelmingly and Simba and
yes our friend Chewbacca defense came in
with what's better than one father three
fathers a baby
Gutenberg's Tom Selleck and Ted Danson
there we go the course is a duo I can't
remember yeah okay
three men in opinion yeah what's that
what which quartet which bother child a
quartet dancing berg stands come for you
oh yeah oh damn damn breaking out a
little Schmo down knowledge right there
alright question number three damn is Oh
Thank You lowly this is good maybe
hopefully we'll find maybe a speed round
opponent for damn gonna take this
question off if you want okay here we go
never all right so I'm gonna read in
this I'm gonna read the question and
then I'm gonna offer you choices you
know I'll offer the choice do not read
these do not read these and then read
the question all right please pick
please pick one
keep a close keep it closed all right
you there in a guy contact with the Hat
okay all right here we go ladies bad
werewolf okay so here it is between
always be my maybe John wick three and
Toy Story 4 it's the summer of Keano the
key honest honest if you will
adding sanso thing you know we should we
should cancel that so it is the summer
of Keanu with that said everybody picked
one paper from the Hat and we asked and
you're at what you picked is your answer
we asked the question what is the best
Keanu Reeves character best Keanu
character alright so let's go around
okay go ahead and open go ahead and open
your papers here
I'll watch their faces as they drink it
in
drink it in alright Dan player number
three goes first on question number
three lay it on us I drew out of the Hat
and I Johnny Utah from Point Break who's
not only the best Keanu Reeves character
he's the most key honorees character I
love a perfect melding of actor and role
and that's what Johnny Utah is a lot of
times Kim who's been an awkward fit and
some of the movies that he's been in
it's a bit of an awkward fit in the role
I think that Point Break is where they
just like ah that's just like the
bullseye that's you dream for that kind
of casting you believe him as a football
player
you believe him as a surfer just about
anything but it's it's what he brings it
just like that early 90s Keanu dude-ness
what Jeff Bridges did for dude-ness in
the early 2000s Keanu did for dude-ness
in the early 90s and I love that you
can't imagine anyone else but Keanu
Reeves playing that character and I
think that's the hallmark of a great
movie character and a great actor in
that role is you cannot imagine anyone
else as Johnny Utah but Keanu Reeves I
think that's what makes it the best key
owner who's character well Dan get the
point with Point Break we'll see around
almost sorry about that around the horn
Spencer I drew a fine choice Ted
Theodore Logan the Bill and Ted series
oh by the way I'm wearing a wild
stallions well I think the thing we love
about Keanu is underneath it all no
matter whether he's John wick or Johnny
you [ __ ] Johnny mnemonic number of
John's is that his core there's a
sweetness to him and nowhere is that
sweetness more on display than in the
Bill and Ted series he's mcnutt's the
entire appeal of Keanu when we first
fell in love with him was as a lovable
dude as like a little bit of an airhead
but a sweet guy who sticks by his
friends and only has the best intentions
at heart and I think that you can add
layers to Keanu as his career goes on
but the gooey center is the sweetness
and
there's Ted Logan at the middle of all
of his characters lovable dude Joe let
me kill 50 dudes in this room right now
cuz I got John wick from the John wick
trilogy I think John wick is the perfect
Keanu balance it has so he just mixes so
many of the things that we love about
Keanu cuz he's not a character actor
that disappears in the thing you're just
gonna get like a tenant of Keanu for
like each of his characters and I think
this one mixes them so so well you get
that bit a Zen you get that bit of like
sadness that sort of is just below the
surface you feel with with with Keanu
Reeves you get that ability to just kill
the hell out of things that he pulls off
so believably well like you believe that
this guy can gun through a room full of
people we also root for John wick in a
real way and not just because we root
for Keanu Reeves although I think that
that's part of it it's big it's because
John wick not only has that blank slate
that we can project our love for Keanu
on to but because of the set up of the
character he lost his wife he lost his
dog he lost the path he lost like the
life that he had worked so hard to build
after leaving behind the garbage we get
a sense that he's fighting to get a
shred of that gooey center back of that
warmth that we like about Keanu back
like the fact that that warmth is
missing from John wick makes us cheer
for more because I think we project him
fighting for to regain that and I just
think that that just makes him such a
meaty character for Keanu to play and
the best game characters fight it out
was like me with the question Reeves
Carey what is the best Keanu Reeves
character to that extent I would argue
that John wick is not the appeal of John
wick it's the direction it's the
choreography it's the stunt crew it's
the it's the style of that film John
wick is kind of a placeholder he's the
boogeyman but I think that John wick if
he's still the same character but you
shoot it like taking three and there's
all these fast cuts in shaky-cam it's
not a good movie
he's a kind of a generic they killed my
wife they killed my dog now I'm gonna
kill them to take it the other way you
could put any current action story you
could put a Donnie Yen in that same
thing and I'm not going to empathize
with with with Yen the same way that I'm
going to empathize with the way that
Keanu Reeves plays John wick I think
it's key otherwise otherwise I think
that this really would have just gone
straight to DVD he's the anchor of it
he's what sells that action
he's what sells your relationship to the
character because you have at the end of
the day you have to care about the
protagonist of an action movie and
that's what makes that character special
you just said a little bit about it
though you said a blank slate that you
project like I care about the dog I was
about the dog I was very upset I mean
that's really the the original sentiment
for this movie it's good for me it's not
about the character of John wick so good
tell me something about John wick he's a
bad he kills a lot of people he's a bad
guy like he don't like I told you he's
rundown he's sad he's broken he's had
something taken from him just because
the the the movie doesn't spend a lot of
time in like flashbacks where you see
him like skipping with his wife and
eight dogs doesn't mean that it's not
there we know just enough to know that
he's lost something and not knowing the
details of that almost makes it
sympathize with the character more it
makes the character even stronger but
it's a little OneNote I think it's like
he's driven by revenge and that's pretty
much all there is a CD or note than
Johnny Utah who was like that see that's
what everyone says about Johnny cute on
the wrong it Ted is an idiot he's good
to love like the lovable idiot he's a
funny idiot but he's an idiot Johnny
Utah look at these different characters
John wick he sees these weeks of one man
Wrecking Curtain squad he's driven by
revenge he's driven by one thing point A
to point B he's a he's a he's a wrecking
ball Ted is a goofily the lovable hi
Laurel he comes through for his friends
he sticks by the mission until much like
John East but the characters are just
there that thing there that one thing
right the other thing about Johnny
telling Superman character he's
conflicted he's a cop but he's torn
between duty and his love for his life
made Bodhi and all of these movies like
Keanu and this good Johnny Utah is the
one character who's actually conflicted
by say it's a tricky question because I
think ken Reeves does the worst out of
all of these with Johnny Utah
the character that killed his career
like that's the one that made him a joke
whereas Dracula made a much yeah did
Johnny Utah he I guess if he ended up
where he began I would buy it but you
never buy that he is a straight-laced
ex-college pro football player he's a
surfer dummy from from scene one of that
movie
I didn't start until speed yeah exactly
hardcore techno that's that's Dracula
which John or Jack is he and speed at
Ravan is when I when I first bought him
as an action character not not Utah Utah
I I think in hinds like in hindsight we
kind of ironically go but I don't think
going into that movie and if any of us
were like hell yeah Johnny you tell you
speak to me and you guys are demeaning
Ted Logan just just my throat casting it
aside as a goof like it like comedic
characters don't count for him to hold
his own as an all-time comedic duo
earnest equal to hold his own with
George Carlin and scenes for someone to
make us laugh and have us fall in love
with them is no easy feat that's almost
way more difficult to me than learning
to reload a gun or take us into your
final thoughts here sure yeah Kiani was
obviously a big part of this question
because he plays all of these characters
which you have to you also have to look
at the characters themselves and I think
the difference between Johnny Utah these
other two characters is that both of
them are a little OneNote they're a
little broad there's not a whole lot of
meat on that bone other than just the of
the essence of what they are and I think
what makes this a great movie and this
is not just I think that a lot of people
consider Point Break just kind of a
featherweight
early 90s action movie I mean this is a
Kathryn Bigelow movie this is this is
one of the better action movies of the
90s and I think part of it is that it's
not just cop chase bad guy and whether
you buy into Johnny Utah or not I think
at the beginning that movie is a guy
who's who's you know works because you
buy in this part of both worlds that's
one of the reasons that he he is in the
world that he's in is because he can
infiltrate and I love the fact that out
of all these characters he's the only
one I actually feel con
Licht from throughout the course of the
movie he's conflicted about what he
should do next he's torn he's morally is
his moral compass is compromised
everything he thinks he knows about
himself as earning the question and
that's just not on a character level I
don't get that from either one of these
two characters justice Wyatt I put
Johnny Utah is the best character in
addition to being just a great Keanu
moment in his filmography of these three
you top all right
I just think Ted two to borrow a phrase
from our host is the most iconic of
these three it made such an impression
on America say what you will about the
character that he struggled his entire
career to overcome Ted we've always
associated him with a character like Ted
of this lovable guy who's very genuine
who finds himself in these crazy
situations and just kind of deals with
it and in the end isn't that what we
love about Keanu Reeves Thank You
Spencer jo I do think that's a good
point with he spent his whole career
sort of trying to overcome Ted and I
don't think he did it with Utah I don't
even think he did it with neo because
there was still that sense of whoa with
neo and people still sort of made fun of
him for that fatness I think John wick
is where he overcame Johnny Utah that's
where he overcomes Ted and really
becomes a really strong strong character
actor
just a lot of internal work Utah's very
external so Ted is a very like external
I you know the kind of like I put on a
silly hat kind of acting whereas
everything that's going on with John
wick is internal it's a motive it's
subtle and I just think that's so so
cool and it's and it's strong enough
that he's able to carry you through
choreography without just being like
this is a video game cutscene at no
point does the the action in the John
wick movies
overwhelm your you're rooting for that
character to get through it to survive
you like you feel the pain with him
every time he's sighs when like
someone's like you're back in and you
see John wick like yeah like you see
like sort of the pain and exhaustion
that goes with like having to
acknowledge that and I think we really
root for him
I think this is the role that has
finally taken all the weird like flavors
of Keano you talk about sort of meat on
characters Johnny Utah isn't meat he's -
meatball subs but like this is where
this is where like all the different
like that's a cool thing about Keanu
that's a cool thing about Keanu that's a
cool thing about Keanu John wick is
where they really all finally come
together as a mature veteran actor
performance for counter beeps thanks Jo
time all right long sticks to the facts
Keano style no real mixed facts this
time everybody was pretty right on how
did you dunno I just looked this up but
I thought was interesting John wick was
originally written to be like in his 60s
like they had pictured of like a Paul
Newman role and that's why he's such
like a mythic figure in the underground
Tianna just nailed the audition and they
just wanted him so they kind of reworked
it to be Keanu Reeves oh wow very cool
and and it's kind of ironic that it was
it's directed by choreographer that
counter raisers worked with
choreographers directed the first crazy
oh right thank you right Miller that
first dimple just a helps kinda I think
it's done thank you uh support uh great
so there was there were so many good
arguments like off-the-cuff you guys all
really brought it Joe that was a
beautiful breakdown at the end about how
John wick like really change counters
career
I don't it was a really impactful
argument I don't feel like it resonated
as his best character but how it turned
what he was known for and gave him this
new life you really summed that up
beautifully dan I
I thought you you were making an
excellent argument but man they kept
dinging you about do we love to kind of
just like bag on Johnny Utah little bit
be caught or is it or is it really
consistent all the way through and no
one brought this up if there's the show
Point Break live which kind of makes fun
but lovingly so but it just brought
enough question for me at the
the day I thought Spencer's final
argument was just nice and concise he's
genuine and lovable and funny and so
many things that he's known for
throughout the decade in the 90s and up
to today
I got to go spending on this along a
really good argument I thought that
Spencer had defeated Joe completely with
the like he spent his whole career
trying to get past Ted and ever that's
the iconic role but they Jill had that
great response that's like yeah and John
which is the role that finally did it I
thought that was a really great response
I'm gonna with Joe right on okay it's a
Joe and Spencer locked at one one
Danielle can you help us out all right
going to the polls fresh off the thing
fresh off the kitchen I don't know at
46% we've got John wick with 28% it is
Ted Logan with 24% in Johnny Utah a lot
of other basically the only two other
things that were in there were Neil or
Keanu Reeves as himself sumio is about
two more on that on here I haven't seen
always be my lady yet driving from
spigen hasn't been hard to argue Kevin
would have been real hard one see where
he's trying to work
it was just cans alright so that means
Joe and Dan are going to Spencer I
thought you two fantastic
thank you for favoring us my good man
hang out yeah alright so it is two for
Dan one for Joe and we go to the speed
round again we ask the question shout
out your answer and then you'll in the
order that you answered you'll have 20
seconds to elaborate each player gets 20
and then followed by ten-second
rebuttals in that same order here we go
question 1 we got a trailer for The
Shining follow up dr. sleep who would
you cast as Jack Torrance in a remake of
The Shining
just stanley kubrick estate a signed off
5-4 mark ruffalo Ruffalo Tom Cruise all
right we got Ruffalo we got crews we'll
start with Joe and Ruffalo first 20
seconds on the clock I think what makes
Jack truly terrifying is that
transformation from dad doing his best
to horrifying door axing monster and I
think Ruffalo could give you both ends
of X spectrum whereas I think Tom Cruise
is already in the picture at the
Overlook Hotel like out the gate
watching Ruffalo fall apart I think
would be really truly terrifying this
sweet man I think watching Ruffalo fall
apart is expected I think Tom Cruise is
somebody that the audience brings their
love into it makes his descent into
madness even more terrifying not just
for the characters on screaming to the
audience he's a great actor and he's got
the chops to pull off nobody's done
genial Jack Torrance I think Mark
Ruffalo's already starts off a little
too edgy you want the guy that goes from
here to here and that's what you're
gonna get with Tom Cruise he's a foot no
one loves Tom Cruise we fear Tom Cruise
we respect Tom Cruise we love Ruffalo
and also this is a journeyman who hasn't
really gotten a chance to break out with
an awesome iconic role and I think Jack
torch would be really cool
I think that Tom Cruise hasn't gotten
the chance to do this kind of role a
true psychopath we've seen fishing
shades of it with things like Magnolia
but I think this is an opportunity and
something that's really special Mark
Ruffalo's done a lot time okay here we
go
first name is ivy Danielle what are you
thinking okay I'm you these were both
fantastic answers I really like the
answer for Mark Ruffalo the talking
about the transformation to dad to
monster why did I write monster Buffalo
that's my the gate but I will say there
was some there was a great argument
about how Mark Ruffalo and of course you
were all dancing around the Hulk I
appreciate the dancing all the nice tap
dancing but I also liked dance argument
about how that seems like it's something
that would be more expected whereas
watching someone go from being the truly
charming you know to stare you right in
the eyes Tom Cruise to someone who goes
super mad would be very compelling so
I'm going with him 104 Tom Cruise and
Dan lon Oh both great outside the box
and answers I wasn't expecting I thought
both fighters did a really great job but
I have to say ultimately I was kind of
more won over by Dan's like Tom Cruise
going from good guy likeable movie star
Tom Cruise to like crazy psychopath that
does sound very compelling I'm going
with them as well damn gonna get that
point dan is taking it to game point
did you have any thoughts on this answer
by the way I was gonna go Shia Oh
oh yeah but yeah letting shy on korkin
like Tom Cruise is nice or one second
the next second ease jumping on the
couch all right here we go question
number two it's game point Joey and you
to keep her going fast and furious we
can't be doing a movie fights without
talking about fast and furious at some
point family oh yes so they're gonna get
an animated series on Netflix called spy
racers franchise originally named adults
would inspire the best cartoon series
thank you sir the premise of that
question no we've really had a full
conversation since I asked me fast and
furious we get an animated series on
Netflix called spy racers what movie
franchise are originally aimed at adults
would inspire the best cartoon series
sure adults yeah what movie it was pg-13
the pg-13 great what would inspire the
best cartoon series silence of the line
oh my lord
Silence of the Lambs we're taught the
island of dr. Moreau was a movie kids oh
do you accept that because in what movie
franchise is the question
I'll step back a movie franchise movie
franchise I mean I think we could accept
yeah yeah it's cool it's cool it's cool
Danielle looks like he's thinking okay
scream great hmm
all right so we have Silence of the
Lambs we have scream dan you answered
first 20 seconds begins when you speak
the best adult movie two cartoon
annotations are the ones that are
hilariously obvious about sanding off
the edges and making it for kids and I
love the idea of taking Hannah by vector
from this it's like let's go dr. Lecter
where you going like I would tune in to
watch that show every single week just
like what Robocop had the show I love
the fact that you take these crazy fun
Ghostface and teen Neve their best
friends that go on adventures they save
people from spooky situations they solve
mysteries they get into wacky gothy
adventures the Beetlejuice cartoon had
nothing to do with Beetlejuice and
people adored it and I think that's what
you do is scream you could sell Ghost
Face plushies and Neve Campbell could
voice the character so she'd come back
movie and scooby-doo I don't need scream
P do I want I know like they're not only
crazy cartoony Hannibal Lecter it would
be hilarious kids would like it adults
would enjoy it I love their already
cartoon characters the problem is I
don't know what your science of the
Lambs cartoon is about whereas Ghostface
and never gonna go on a horror movie
rule based adventures it's gonna be
super fun super exciting kids are going
to adore it and silence of alright Wow a
lot of fun stuff here Dan you get a
point for screen B do on my Hana meter
just coming up with that all the dome
very impressive but my point for this
round goes to Jo because
I could actually see what his was and I
have a hard time just seeing how exactly
yours would translate damper so I'm
going one for Joe Danielle yeah I gotta
agree as much as I do want to watch and
see how they make cuddly Silence of the
Lambs Joe had a very clear pitch for
whatever his movie was gonna be and he
especially I like that he waited until
the end to give me the knock out with
what that we hadn't seen that from yours
that was a fantastic offensive move so
I'm going with Joe Joe you got that
point it's three two here we go still
game point for Dan and let's ask this
men and black international hits
theaters this weekend which classic Will
Smith film should get a sequel next wild
wild west or Hancock wild wild west ok
we have Dan with Wild West Joe you got
Hancock by default Joe Joe just got
Hancock damn 20 seconds when you waste
week while a lot of les has the best
thing that you want when you're making a
sequel which is untapped potential
there's so many crazy things that you
can do that were not explored in the
first movie you can go back you can
correct the mistakes that were done the
first time Hancock is over that story's
over anything added to that story is
superfluous so you're just gonna be
forcing these characters back together
when the whole point is that they need
to be a part wild wild west can actually
redeem I think Wild West has unlimited
potential but it wouldn't it would just
be another bland men and black
international sort of look I don't know
here it is
whereas Hancock as a deconstruction
superhero movie now has a decade of MCU
of a DC movie attempts of watchman's of
this's and that's to look back and
comment on and deconstruct and I think
that's why Hancock stood out it was
interesting watchman's already a
deconstruction superhero films and the
Marvel movies themselves are starting to
be deconstruction to superhero them so
we don't need another one of those I
want something they can go to a mistake
that was made in the past and correct it
and make something better and that's
what you'll get
I think that's a weird place to start
your moving from hey we're sorry we're
gonna do better this time whereas
Hancock I think could be fresh and have
more to say and bring in Will Smith
really strong and really confident and
really like and take BMC you down a peg
okay
long where are you at on this one Joe
came out so good in the first round I
was really like yeah like this is a
great case for why you would do more
with a that but I felt like it kind of
fell apart at the egg and about Dan sort
of finished stronger with there's so
much in this world of wild-west that you
could try to do again I have to go with
that yeah I thought I also thought Dan
had strong arguments and nice parrys to
Joe's effective arguments so I go down
as well dan you just one movie fight not
good I'm sorry I don't know it's a
pleasure fighting I'd like to fight yeah
this is fun for me I hope it's fun for
you this is fun for me yeah you're a
sinister wordsmith you did forensics in
high school right so yeah debate in high
school yeah mmm very nice very nice
damn any any anything else any shoutouts
any box office predictions for the
weekend um yeah yeah Toy Story 4 it's
great you can see that review over on
fandom entertainment right now yeah
looks like it might be another whole
home weekend with men in black opening
we'll see but but yeah look look forward
to a story for because it's a it's
really really I liked a lot so it opens
next week so really nothing for this
week ok bide your time until yeah it's a
good 2 hours in the air conditioning
that was good cool thank you dan Joestar
fun stuff all day long very happy to be
a part of this edition as we do the
farewell tour to the weekly iteration of
movie fights very happy to be a part of
the Dan Morrill Invitational I don't
think the show would have lasted more
than four episodes if you weren't in it
so yeah this is a lot of fun super fun
thanks Joe and Sir Gilbert uh call your
father's this weekend right of a card do
more than text don't slide into your
dance again give him a thumbs up it gave
me my life give him a card that's a hard
Jesus coming in with this Father's Day
hot tanks Thank You Spencer we get a you
procreated
blonde hair thank you sir for holding it
down in the fact zone
my pleasure I also love dads I'm not one
but good job dad what about your like
dads we're not fathers I'm so Daniel
Radford I only like daddies what is that
what is that fall I think it's just
February 14th weird section at hallmark
today a new Eddie Murphy movie Zadi
daycare bring it back Big Daddy uh thank
you guys thanks everybody thanks JT e
and Billy biz ladies
yeah don't forget to sign your dad's DMS
and hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at how rudnick for lots of fun dumb
stuff and thanks for watching everybody
damn know we'll see you out let's do
this again next week huh well this is a
humdinger on board for next
I know let's put this get busy alright
tune in next week and you're watching
you